hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to uni camstudio back
into the empire back to being creepy
okay wow that was not how I wanted to
start this episode I apologize for that
everybody well we're gonna get going on
this and it's gonna be real good oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be I'm gonna do this full emo
mode because I know that for me to run
this Empire my heart needs to be
blackened dead that cut that out this is
embarrassing
okay so we're gonna get back into it so
everyone is doing their thing she just
got out of relaxing and she's gonna make
a lot of money in there she's making way
more money than she was before and
admittedly
that's good because she's rolling into
the other these words pop it was just me
dating it was me pathetically dating now
I get no action no love and I have to
stand on the sidelines and talk about
predators ah not exactly my ideal
scenario but it's okay we'll see if I
was even smarter I realize now that I
shouldn't have even benefited everybody
from like training for the fashion
because it was like a waste of time and
nobody actually needed that so we're
gonna just keep her going in their way
okay so there's actually no one I
believe that has watersports involved so
I'm gonna get rid of the water bottle
and then give her more sugar I'm trying
my innocence is very delicate right now
I need to need to cherish it as much as
I can why are they relaxing so much too
many people are relaxing
we need people on the job we need people
making money
looks like Kiana and Nikki are my main
earners right now which is actually kind
of good Oh Audrey oh how are you doing
now if you thought Audrey was a [ __ ]
then you never met Lillian Lillian Wow
Lillian doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything
Lillian is just mean
and cold-hearted and admittedly I do
need someone from the goth section of
things with tattoos because a lot of the
promo that I've been getting has been
towards that but that being said but
that being said oh she's got too much in
fashion that's right we don't need that
what we do need man it's either go with
the meanie puss that you know or go with
the Meany puss that you don't know and I
gotta go with Audrey she's got a special
place in my heart
oh come on dree how I missed you you are
just so delightful and see the funny
thing is I'm kind of assembling a crew
of just huniepop characters that might
be a little biased to me I don't know
it's like whatever you know I won't
judge if you won't judge but to be
honest I'm better I mean I haven't seen
the other girls in their non huniepop
things and there's like no Celeste I
don't know why there isn't like Celeste
or Venus or Momo there's like none of
those characters in this game and I
thought there would be but apparently
not what are you oh come on it's not
that big a deal just do your job and
then have fun with it shove this up your
butt because you got a stick up there
anyway so just go on with your life so
that we can all live a long time your
crap compete good for you easy peasy who
knew so easy to be a let's player and do
Let's Plays for everyone all around the
world I mean I wonder I really wondered
because okay you can make like a channel
on websites like pornhub and such not
that I've ever done it but you will
oddly find some of my videos on board up
like oh man I forget what the title of
what it was someone posted like the
space is so cool song and said yes yeah
yes I
your porn my phone but not just
everybody shut up I'm just looking at
myself oh my god someone someone posted
like something from Mario maker and it
says the sexy interracial man releases
his anger and there's more stuff like
that so yeah that's that's um that's on
there and so you know interracial sexy
goof shoves bread into his fury oh this
is so cool Zorgon said interracial sexy
freak is taken to infinity and beyond so
yeah that was it that's it yep that's
the one okay good for me so yeah that's
that's that's what to expect if you were
to go there so yeah I need to get as
many items as possible because right now
apparently these microphones are very
important we gotta get them gotta get
her down on stress so that she can keep
moving forward because she's one that's
coked up out of her mind I mean sugar
god damn it
yes new ones that's a lot of money
Oh got it because I have a lot of money
because I'm very good at what I'm doing
shut up you have a lot of things that
you need to do before you can be doing
what you need to do okay so you
oh my god shut up with their stupid
shove this up your bike seriously now
you can make a lot of money it's good
you're suddenly a very good earner it's
let's see I got enough
I got enough microphones you get more
butt plugs though the day I've been
waiting to say that to myself oh I need
more butt plugs the max number of items
that you can actually have is three so
I've got enough of those and I don't
think okay so anyway so I'm gonna give
this to her as will oh [ __ ] we're out of
round of cigarettes what the hell
happened yeah Cakes hit the cake farts
there you go just pick up some smokes
[ __ ]
how many fans yeah not enough oh [ __ ]
she didn't have the basket that's right
why was I Oh cuz she was Oh cuz she was
moving very fastly cuz now now Lola is
making proper amount of money which is
good so we just need to diversify
everything else that we have and be able
to do that she's stressed so she's going
in there but eventually when she's out
she's gonna get more booze because
everyone else is getting stressed out of
their mind fail shut up I know you're
addicted to booze okay so now I just
gotta have dedicated someone going into
the going into the just literally
someone's dedicated to always making
booze runs and cigarette runs it looks
like Tiffany's gonna be the one for that
so good for her
what do you have good glad okay so we're
gonna have to ffunny go in there and
you're gonna start distress okay
what what do you have okay so you make
good enough money that I think now I'm
gonna Kia outside later outside later I
gotta get you up to level
yeah level five the pole you too
stressed out in well damn it get out of
there everybody's in there Kanade get in
there wow that was a lot of money okay
you go you're suddenly new earner that's
amazing actually
oh no Jesse's out of coke what are we
gonna do I don't know I just need to do
this because everyone else is stressed
the ones who drink and smoke are based
entirely off of this so they need to be
in there so I'm gonna get her in the
strip club
yes go back ok go there ok you're good
there you'd be stress okay so I think
it's about time we get belly because
belly has a lot of fans baseline anyway
and she doesn't drink or smoke a lot
which means that we are going to have a
good old time with her on the team
thanks for being your belly I'm gonna
give you a whole bunch of interesting
devices and I'm gonna leave it up to you
to decide what to do with them
good great cat ears very good I think oh
[ __ ] that wasn't a good one
Oh No furries all the way down here damn
it
all the top one was bondage these things
so weird okay so take that oh my I know
it's a little bizarre now I have to
determine if Abel is up above cake
farting okay cake farting is way down we
don't need cake farting up in here shove
this up your butt please
thank you thank you for being so
understanding now we got the level four
rushing so that we may get a lot more
done you're very valuable to the team
and I kind of have devised an entire
roster of just people from uni pop which
is totally cool cuz I like him a lot
- they're nice people good job
well now [ __ ] I just sent her there
oopsies oopsy poopsy z-- oopsy poopsy
z-- so now Nikki's officially top dog so
she can make so much money
what no money okay so now you're done
finally maximum capacity of the cam show
that's horrible can you have yeah you
have room for this god damn it you don't
have any good good to know I don't care
I just need to get through this much
faster than the duration that I'm doing
it more booze we demand more booze there
must be constant influx of booze and
boobs
okay so belly is almost level five pole
dancing which means that she's okay we
got more all right that fake-ass free
mil thick cake Ferdinand fit hey that's
good I'm happy
Wow
four thousand belly you're doing so oh
[ __ ] I didn't I goddamn it I didn't even
get her level up oh it's not gonna count
now what an [ __ ] I am
goddamn them so should you
fine whatever do what you want I need to
upgrade that we need to have yeah we
need to have five people in a building
at once otherwise we're not gonna be
able to do anything you need to go shop
okay now the problem is the amounts of
money are getting way too high that I'm
not able to do what I need to do but
this is okay cuz everything is fine it's
a good problem to have too much money it
is definitely a good problem down high
that's good okay so now the official
problem is not money anymore so we need
to collaborate on getting everyone up on
the right attitudes which means that we
need to put okay she already has
something up her butt so we don't need
to worry about that that's totally fine
but now this you no longer have that you
don't need that you need to be coked up
out of your mind damn oh we don't have
that you look fine
Lola dear you are looking at delightful
this no it's not shut up can you get
that out of there can you put this take
the cake oh you're full up yeah I'm
feeling fine feeling fine it's not
stressed at all everything's good
you go there yes very I know man it's
starting to get really expensive okay
this this next round is needs to be
coordinated so we need this we need
that teen latina okay and that's good
for now all right so now even okay
now this is the moment that I've been
waiting for this is why I've been
holding out cuz she actually know would
it be better to save these okay I'm just
gonna I'm gonna save these I'm gonna
give her this and she's gonna go in here
so now what's happening is we are still
doing the exact same thing we were doing
for literally nothing is you nothing at
all so don't worry about a goddamn thing
we're doing fine nobody panic
even though this obviously no reason to
panic why would anyone be panicking
it's all cool just get in the camstudio
it's cool it's actually a little better
to coordinate everyone to go in the
studio at the same time so that you're
able to take advantage of everyone
moving up and because when someone makes
money you have to take the time to be
able to get the money out so it takes
more time so you gotta like stack them
on top of each other sometimes but that
can't happen if you want to keep
everybody moving forward so you do it
can it makes sense no get back in cuz
you wanna make you want to like
coordinate it so that the the easy
things are done when they're done like
the easy things keep going by themselves
because it'll eventually collect the
money by themselves and you want to make
sure that everything else is kept moving
forward in a very orderly fashion that's
a lot of money that I got to take out of
there
gotta invest in this damn it this dammit
this this dammit so much money so much
money it's too much of a problem too
much money there we go now we got all
those for the day then we'll be able to
pay everybody else because we're making
so much money another butt plug I
demanded I demand more plugs of but I
shouldn't shout that at the top of my
lungs I really should be careful about
what I'm screaming about
ah but clucks I demand more butt plugs
more bugs I don't know what I'm gonna do
with more blood plugs I have too many
butt plugs I've got I've got too many
bot bugs
god dammit never thought I'd have this
problem I've even got too many things
okay so now okay hop everybody hold up
for a second
first I'm gonna pay you guys okay so who
has the most fans okay looks like Keanu
has the most fans way to go Keanu Wow
nice okay but belly has the most
training so I need to get either Keanu
into training or actually you Jesse okay
all right so Jesse no yeah no yeah okay
so Jesse has an open space so I'm gonna
give her a condom she's gonna go into
this hotel sleep and do nothing else and
then mysteriously find money that's how
it works nobody questioned it that's how
it works
so don't question a thing she's sleeping
she stumbled across money and it's
totally cool everything's fine don't
worry about it okay so I'm gonna keep
the last one because I actually want to
hold off because late game it becomes
very valuable to hold on to as many
condoms is possible for sleeping
purposes and finding mattress money
purposes wink
but anyway so now that I got that done
and it got everything done in an orderly
fashion we are in much better shape than
we were so I'm gonna pause it here and
end this episode thank you everybody so
much for watching we're doing pretty
good I don't know if we're doing better
than my original run last time but we're
doing
pretty good so thank you everybody so
much for watching it has always and why
is this looming forever